no scuffed intro today guys that's
because there's just
too much to talk about everything from
hints at new parks that deciphered audio
message from the insight website and yes
it has been deciphered and just what the
hell happened to bernard in the sublime
we have theories on the man in black
will caleb be back and is dolores gone
for good
we're gonna cover all this and a ton
more but before we do i just wanted to
say thank you to everyone who has
followed my westworld videos over the
past three months
this will likely be my last westworld
video before season 4 stuff starts
coming out a million years from now so
if you haven't already
make sure to like and subscribe i cover
tons of other shows and movies so you'll
want to stick around for that finally
i've left timestamps to
all the topics i cover in the
description below so if you want to skip
ahead to a certain theory or discussion
do so at your own peril we may as well
start with the big cliffhanger bernard
and the sublime
at the end of season 3 we learned that
he was the one that held the encryption
key
allowing him access to the quote-unquote
host heaven
the sublime right before he goes offline
we see this
tear here which is quite similar to the
tear the host went
through to reach the sublime in season
two bernard also looks in
awe of something here but we aren't sure
if this is something new or if he's just
stunned by the beauty of the sublime
that being said there is a
ton to unpack here first let's talk
about the amount of time that has passed
from when bernard went offline to his
awakening
the producers have said this is far in
the future but never specified a date
the amount of dust here suggests decades
and the fact
no one at the motel where he's staying
at came to check up on him
implies some sort of catastrophic event
that has taken place
in my westworld season 3 timeline video
i hinted that we could be anywhere from
50 to 125 years in the future if
solomon's prediction showing the end of
civilization is correct
so what does this mean for season 4 most
likely
multiple timelines both in real world
and
digital timeline 1 would focus on
bernard and his quest for answers in the
sublime
the only images of the sublime we've
seen are at the end of season 2
where it looks like the hosts have to
start anew but who is to say the sublime
doesn't already have
town cities and who knows what else then
there's the question
of time itself does the sublime operate
in real time or does it move
faster or slower remember when maeve was
in surak's war world simulation that
time in the sim ran at a faster speed
than the real world
when she checks on the security camera
footage in the real world everything is
slowed down
who is to say that the same isn't true
for the sublime
even though we see bernard covered in
dust for what maybe
a hundred years it's entirely possible
in his mind he was only gone for a few
days
or it could be the other way around he
could have been in the sublime for
hundreds of years
then there's the question of what he did
there we know he's looking for an answer
for quote
what comes after the end of the world
but who would he get this answer from
the two main characters from previous
seasons that we know made it to the
sublime are
teddy and akichita i doubt that teddy
will have some mind-blowing answer
hidden away that will save humanity
maybe a kichita does prior to the
formation of delos akichita worked for
the argos initiative the development
project formed by robert ford and arnold
weber that would later turn
into delos destinations it's possible he
has some inside information about what
these two had planned
and knowing bernard has part arnold's
memories stored inside him maybe
a kichita can bring those out i think
the most likely scenario however
involves new characters or
bringing back some iteration of ford or
arnold
if the producers are going to play with
the timeline set in the sublime they'll
need a whole new cast of characters and
obstacles to get in bernard's way
including a new villain
then there's the question of stubs
considering bernard is still
left alone collecting dust it's safe to
assume stubs bled out in that tub
and went offline as well i'd imagine if
he did
manage to get out he'd get help and come
back for bernard especially since he was
programmed to protect him the writers
could also play with we the viewers
never seeing what bernard goes through
in the sublime the show hides
information from the viewers all the
time but in this scenario we lose the
fun of exploring a new world with new
possibilities
but we still have another two timelines
to talk about
let's discuss present day or the events
shortly after the riots in los angeles
this timeline would focus on caleb
alongside maeve leading a resistance
against
charlotte in an interview with the
guardian way back in october of 2019
actor aaron paul said quote i've got a
year and a half hiatus between
seasons of westworld enough time to pack
on a bunch of weight and
lose it if i wanted to this pretty much
confirms that he'll be back or has
at least signed a multi-season contract
with the show
the fact that he's already talking about
packing on weight could mean
playing a beefed up resistance leader
like john connor
in the terminator films a transformation
also suggests some time will pass
between the start of the riots
and his ascension as leader of humanity
this also leaves maeve who at the end of
season 3
said she'll find her daughter just not
today maeve's daughter is in the sublime
and who just traveled there
bernard so it's likely these two will
meet up then there's charlotte who has
taken control of delos and created an
army of hosts
with the world in disarray this is the
perfect opportunity for her to
capitalize on the situation
and take over whether this is done
forcefully or whether she uses hosts to
infiltrate key positions of power around
the globe
remains to be seen but if solomon's
prediction is correct we'll be seeing
mass casualty events in the upcoming
years
charlotte also has a host version of
william it remains to be seen what his
rule will be in season four
but it's possible he could be used as
some sort of mole within caleb's
resistance
after all no one hates can openers more
than him this also raises several
questions about that post-credit scene
at the end of season 2 which takes place
in the far
future and is the third timeline i want
to discuss
in this scene we learn that westworld is
long gone and william has been through
many
iterations the post-apocalyptic feel is
quite similar to that of bernard's motel
room when he awakens
these scenes could take place around the
same time but jonathan nolan in an
interview with the hollywood reporter
said that this scene takes place very
very far in the future and is the
furthest they've gone in the show
including that scene with bernard the
question remains however
what happened to charlotte's william how
did he get to this point
or the writers could simply dismiss it
as being a dream or hallucination which
i think would be a cop-out a fun idea
the writers could play with is if we had
two williams one fighting for humanity
and the other for the hosts
one of westworld's major themes this
season was choice do we make our own or
are they decided for us
having two williams with diametrically
opposed wants making their own choices
could further this theme the far future
also implies that caleb and
any of our human characters that we know
are dead
unless of course caleb's memory gets
implanted in a host or he has children
that can continue humanity's resistance
one character we haven't talked about
yet is dolores we last saw her memory
get wiped and actress evan rachel wood
has said that this version of dolores is
gone
but it's more than likely she'll be back
in one form or another
that's not even including the multiple
doloresses still
out there remember that delores
implanted copies of herself in four
different hosts the fifth pearl she took
out of westworld was not her
rather bernard charlotte has proven that
these copies can make their own choices
and follow their own paths
so we still have lawrence out there the
erased version of dolores still attached
to rehoboam
connell's copy which charlotte grabbed
while escaping delos
and musashi's which hanario took with
her while taking out his severed head
so we still have many doloreses that can
be brought back
the lawrence and musashi dolores would
know that bernard has the key
but not exactly where bernard is and
judging by no one finding him in the
future it looks like he's been forgotten
clementine and henrio are back and will
likely team up with
maeve and caleb i also want to talk
briefly about sorak i don't think he's
needed in season 4 his story seemed
pretty complete but since we never see
him die it's always a possibility he
could return
i want to take a moment and talk about
some of the interesting hints that the
various westworld affiliated websites
have given us
for those of you who don't know and i'll
leave links in the description below
delos and insight both have their own
fake websites created by
hbo the delos destinations website says
the park is currently offline
but you can check out its various parks
including this one
notice how it's almost indecipherable
with jumbled text
scrolling near the bottom reddit user
cole hoppisis
found out this is a castle in germany we
also saw when bernard and stubbs break
into the mesa that there is a medieval
component that even has dragons and some
intrepid redditors were able to decipher
the jumbled text by isolating it frame
by frame
these messages include to be stabbed in
the back but though who perish in the
dance throne
your destiny land of duels are manifold
on the quest
for and finally if your tastes tend
towards royalty embrace
and yes dragons beware the dangers let's
also not forget that the showrunners of
game of thrones made a cameo this season
so these are major clues that this park
is some sort of
fantasy world personally this feels more
like fan service than a hint at what
might be in store in season 4 but then
again with westworld you never know
in the bottom right hand corner you can
also see a customer representative
named aiden if you click on it he says
i'm sorry i'm experiencing some
unfortunate technical difficulties i
hope to begin assisting you in your life
without limits shortly
you'll notice that certain letters are
capitalized here making out the word
goodbye if you type that in you get a
message from dolores
i hate goodbyes luckily i've been
fortunate enough to remember very few of
them
my time watching over this place has
come to an end if you're reading this
and this is now i've entered through the
door
i've spent a lot of time with your kind
and i'd like to believe
you are one of the good ones the words
parche do
are short for parche domine in latin
which means
spare lord it also happens to be the
title of episode 1
of season three this time however it
ends with parche dolores
spare dolores she has crossed into the
door a new world
almost like an eternal godlike figure as
of the writing of this video i've been
unable to find out if there are any
further things you can ask to trigger a
new response
the second site i want to talk about is
insight which after the end of season 3
has seemingly been hacked if you've
subscribed to insight's mailing list you
would have gotten this
email in your inbox which has been taken
over and a picture of the maze from
season 1
is shown investigating further this mail
was sent from 30 hudson yards new york
and is the third largest building in
manhattan
it appears that in the year 2058 insight
owns part if not all of the building
which is ironic since currently part of
the building is rented out by facebook
which also has a past of gathering users
personal information
if you head to the insight website now
your browser quickly glitches
and takes you to this screen but some
users have found there are some
clickable text which can take you to two
other
sites the first is this which is titled
block six
alpha one and appears to show the data
screen when dolores memories were being
wiped by sorak
the second is a login screen for the
ricoh app it asks for a keygen and if
you type in the password free will with
three
dollar signs it says all on him now
better not f it up
and the images on the left change to the
same image i received in that insight
email
an image of what appears to be a man
trapped within a maze
if you continue on to insight you're met
with this distorted audio clip
this is what it sounds like before it's
been cleaned up
youtube user jcpus i hope i pronounced
that right reached out to me and was
able to decipher the end portion by
reversing the audio
dragging the tracks around and enabling
phase cancellation
this is what he was able to get which is
how i know
i'm not the only one who can lay a trap
which is how i know
i'm not the only one who can lay a trap
it's clearly delores now this could be a
reference to her taking down rehoboam in
episode 8
or as reddit user vertical prism noted
it could be a way for dolores to let
charlotte know she has a back-up plan
either way i'm going to be keeping an
eye on this and hopefully someone will
be able to decipher the first half
now let's get into some wild
speculations for season 4.
in an interview with variety showrunner
jonathan nolan stated that the show
strives to reinvent itself every season
it would be fun to see a
post-apocalyptic world with bernard and
sublime
and how poetic would it be if bernard is
the one who has to resurrect dolores
just like
she resurrected him at the beginning of
season 3. in the far future we may even
see a world where hosts come to visit
humans at a park well maybe not a park
it could just be the world itself
a complete reversal of season one this
time it's the humans who have to rise up
but eventually what i think the show has
to end with is some sort of hybrid world
where humans and hosts become one
bernard is already kind of there having
taken elements of arnold's past
it just seems fitting that the fate of
the world does not belong to host
nor human but some sort of combination
of the two
until we get more information we're very
much in the dark heck
season 4 hasn't even been written be
sure to leave a like and subscribe
and thanks again for checking out my
westworld videos come follow me on
twitter at thingstoryt
and until next time remember daddy loves
you very much
you